hello contenders hyperescape is the new
100
urban fast-paced battle royale that will
take you to new heights with its unique
verticality
it's fresh out of open beta and free to
play now on pc
xbox one and ps4 over the next few weeks
we're going to equip you with
everything you need to decipher the code
and become victorious
who's the winner how you ask we'll be
breaking down hyperscape with some of
your favorite streamers who've already
been
in the trenches of competitive play
we're going to be getting insight from
developers who've helped create this
world
and we're going to give you a chance to
discover the truth
behind hyperescape's gameplay and beyond
and you'll only be able to find it here
welcome to the pod
if you're familiar with battle royale
games then you already know that up to
100 players
are dropping into the action what you
don't know is that hyperescape
isn't like other battle royale games
here is where
faster paced vertical mobility and
positional precision
are vital in an ever evolving atmosphere
both when it comes to the 100
urban environment and even down to the
way you experience the game you'll have
a variety of weapons to find as you drop
in
empty-handed but the gun is only half
the battle
the unique hack system will allow you to
craft a build that is the best fit for
your playstyle
whether you like to stay stealthy and
sneak up on your opponents
or if you like to do massive damage and
make those hard-hitting plays
and these are only a few of the
possibilities but of course
none of that is to discredit the arsenal
of weapons suited for many preferences
like the harpy
for the rapid-fire smg fans or the
protocol 5
for those with an eye for a devastating
sniper rifle
just to name a few the fuse system will
make all of your favorite weapons and
hacks
even better see a duplicate of what you
have pick it up and it will fuse with
your current item
to make it even better than before you
can fuse up to four times and maximize
your power
with each level your weapons magazine
size and damage can increase
or your hex down could decrease
throughout this series we'll be getting
insight from some of the best
to drop into the hyperscape to give you
tips on some optimal weapons
hacks and strategies that can help
secure the win in different scenarios
so if you've already seen some weapons
or hacks and you want to know more about
them
then wait until you see what our guests
have to say
whether you are playing or watching
hyperscape is all about keeping you
involved and will reward you either way
in game expect to always be on the move
alive
or dead being taken down doesn't mean
you're taken out
you can still maneuver and scout among
your teammates as an echo until they
secure a revive point for you by finding
a kill or finding a revive point along
the way
living enemies cannot see you which is
perfect for helping your teammates stay
aware of your surroundings to bring you
back safely
but hyperescape goes even further to
keep you involved
even when you aren't playing the twitch
integration allows viewers
to vote on in-game events that can help
or hurt the players depending on how our
audience is feeling that day
infinite ammo anti-gravity and reveal
events are just a few options you could
throw into the chaos
and now that you have a brand new
100-tier battle pass waiting to be
completed
it's worth noting that you can score
points towards your past by simply
watching hyperscape on twitch new weapon
skins new deployment pods and a whole
lot more
can be unlocked without ever moving a
muscle but at some point
all of that watching will get you
itching to play and the twitch
integration has got you covered there
too
streamers will be able to easily invite
viewers to their lobby through the
stream's interface
making it easier than ever to hop in and
play when that time comes we want to
make sure that you are equipped both
physically
and mentally for the battles that are
headed your way
we mentioned earlier that we would be
featuring special guests
in this series to help you on your
journey and i know
the anticipation is killing you but
you're just gonna have to tune in next
week to see who our very first
special guest is we'll even be having
all of our guests check out some of the
community's most
high plays and hype moments while
they're here
so submit your best clips using hashtag
hyperescape on twitter
for a chance to be featured before we go
any further it's important to know
what's new with hyperscape
the open beta gave us a taste of what to
expect
but now there are even more options
available to you
beta or not a brand new weapon and a
brand new hack are now available
and everyone's gonna be on an even
playing field when it comes to the
dragonfly
and the magnet the dragonfly is a new
gun that the silent types will
enjoy this semi-automatic precision
rifle will help you stay quieter than
most and
still pack a punch the magnet is a new
hack that will attract and retain
enemies caught in its area of effect in
such a fast-paced game this hack will
give you the perfect opportunity
to keep them still and secure the kill
next week
we'll get some first impressions on the
dragonfly and the magnet from our
special guest
and see how it's changed the game's meta
but that isn't all that's new there will
also be
new limited time game modes on the way
soon and one more new feature you'll be
able to find during your battles to
learn more about the hyperscape universe
week by week there will be memory shards
placed throughout the sectors
that will expand what we know about the
story of hyperscapes
these memory shards may not always be
easy to find but
we're here to help as always make sure
you stay tuned to the end of every
single episode
to get your exclusive hint on where to
find memory shards
as new ones will be placed every single
week before we go you may be wondering
when can i start looking for them the
answer is right now
and here's your first hint
you